[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ernie johnson segway
ernie johnson jr by the way inside the
nba
sports emmy award-winning studio show
they have a documentary it's a four-part
documentary series
and uh it first part was last night
first episode aired last night part two
tonight
it's the role player at nine eastern and
uh ernesto johnson jr iii
joining us on the program good morning
ernie
and i think uh good morning dan i think
the answer to your question is why do
those ufos never land as if
if they did see our show they would just
zip past that's that's for sure how are
you doing this morning i'm doing great
i'm doing great paulie brought up a
question to me
right before i uh turned on the
microphone to talk to you and he said
how did ernie get the job as the host of
inside the nba how did how did you get
that
i was working in atlanta at um
a station you remember local station
there because you were at cnn at the
time i was working for wsb i was the
weeknd sports anchor
and folks at turner called one day
and said hey would you want to come and
work with us
because we have this role for you as
the host of our wide world of sports
type show called u.s
olympic gold and so we'd like you to
host that for about a year and then
and then become the host of the goodwill
games in seattle
and i said that sounds uh that sounds
good i'll do that there was really not
much talk about the nba at that point
um as things worked out there was a bit
of a power struggle at the top of the
goodwill games organization
in between the time i was hired and the
time that the goodwill games happened
and so
larry king became the host and he had uh
hannah storm and nick charles as his
co-hosts and and i was assigned to uh
to all the sports that beau doesn't know
as i referred to it at that point
judo team handball
um modern pentathlon
i was uh i was kind of a
jack-of-all-trades covering things at
the goodwill game so
that didn't exactly shake out the way it
was supposed to but uh
but certainly in the long run when when
they asked me to
to host the nba that was a that was a
pretty good career move
what was it like when barkley first came
to town
oh i think we're all pumped i mean who
wouldn't be
because this was like landing the
biggest free agent in history
uh this was you know this was um
and especially what made it even even
better
i in a way was we had kind of resigned
ourselves to the fact that he was going
to go to nbc
you know that you know he'll be over
there with them and but will keeps doing
our thing and kenny and i you know
really enjoyed working together but man
when you land that
it's like oh this is going to be this is
going to be so much fun and my only
question at the time was
when the novelty wears off is charles
going to say okay that's enough of this
i've done three shows now what else is
there in my life so
um fortunately he's been he's been with
us for like
21 years or 20 years now so uh
nah it's he's been dan as you know he's
been tremendous and
and the whole key to that is he hasn't
changed from the
the person he was as a player to the
person he is on tv
uh and i think that see that's the
danger if you say all of a sudden
yeah i've been kind of this outspoken
guy and always you know is
always opinionated but when the red
light goes on now i'm i'm gonna
hush up and that's he's been
so far over over the edge on that it's
not even funny
and i know that um i don't mean this
literally of rehearsing how much
rehearsing do you do
but we have these meetings before show
where you kind of go over topics that
you're going to bring up or
you might clue somebody in on a joke
that you might a prank you play on
somebody else but
how much of what is said on the show
itself are you aware of before the show
um none of it really from those guys
no not from them because because the
production meeting i'm in there with tim
kiley and
jeremy levin who's ever producing that
night and you know and about
20 25 other people are on the call now
on these zoom
production meetings oh shaq and charles
and kenny aren't
in on no no no no no no no they've never
been and
okay and the thing is uh part of that
was
by design but part of it was late they
were like i'm not gonna sit
in a meeting for three three hours
before we go on the air and it just
works out better for us because
if we do have something we want to
spring on kenny you know
an old piece of video where he gets his
pocket picked at mid court somebody
dunks
we don't want him saying oh yeah kenny
get ready because in the third segment
of post game we're going to show
this so that's what we want to do we
just want to be able to
spring things on people and like the
other night we
we you know made up this game show for
shaq
based on the fact that he you know
pascal siacom the week before i had said
you got your eye on pascal and he said
no i'm i'm
i've got my own sea outcome and it's
like so the
next week we had a game show on the air
and could could you name the
what's the first name of these players
and and i told them and i even told shaq
i said look
here's here's our stat sheet that we get
from elias or whoever
you know so every every name i'm going
to give you it's it's either in the top
20 of the department or the top 10 of
the department
so you know you know here it is here's
the last name
monk he plays for charlotte eli
no malik okay and it was
it was just what we did but do the
producers have the green light ernie i
know
it feels like the talent has the green
light but producers poking
hall of fame players everything
are you allowed to you know suggest
something that might
hurt somebody's feelings or make them
uncomfortable yeah i think we've
i think we've done this long enough to
know that no one's feelings are gonna
get hurt
uh if that were if that were the case
then we there wouldn't be a docu-series
right now people would have bailed on
the show
uh i'm talking about people who were on
the show
long ago because every every one of us
has been uh
has been in the in the crosshairs from
the other guys so
but shaq does poke charles it feels like
there's a little bit more tension
no it's man did you see shaq the other
night
on the wrestling thing yeah okay
shaq knows drama shaq knows tv
shaq knows what's good you know so if
shaq's gonna raise his voice at chuck
because they can't agree on exactly
where kristaps porzingis should be
in the dallas offense it's it's not that
they're going to step out in the parking
lot
it's just you know it's it's good
conversation but it's never forced it's
never something like
well shaq's just going to take this
position so that we can have an argument
on the air it's just these guys have
different philosophies on the game
so um no but please rest assured there
is not going to be this
heavyweight bout of you know 700 pounds
of
humanity wrestling on the floor i'd like
to see it
but no have you ever gotten hurt have i
ever gotten hurt
on the show doing what like you're
sort of in between those guys or you're
just sort of
an innocent bystander then you somehow
you're getting you know it's collateral
damage
no dan you know me i'm a sensitive guy
i've only had my feelings hurt there's
been no physical pain
it's emotional emotional thing i get it
uh why are we having all-star weekend
well um i think because uh it's a
tradition
and it's because uh obviously there are
monetary
issues that uh you know i'm the last guy
to ask about
what something's gonna mean from a
fiscal standpoint
but i think i mean the commissioner was
pretty forthright about that he said
yeah
look we want to do this and it looks
like the fans want it because there's so
much
voting and that kind of thing but he
also was like look we need to
we need to do this financially and so
uh having it in atlanta certainly
reduces all the
uh the travel for all of our folks
because you know we have the game on tnt
so there's nobody flying cross country
or flying here and there and that kind
of thing and
all the equipment's here so uh that's i
that's why we're having it i was
surprised you know i i didn't think
you know when the word came down that
that there was going to be one i was
surprised
i thought uh just from my view it was
going to be well let's
hey let's get to the all-star break and
then everybody sit back and take a deep
breath and say hey
we did this all right now now what can
we do on the second half
but um but again they have their reasons
for doing it and i
i'm in a few hours i'm heading down to
uh
to the omni hotel to uh quarantine for a
couple of days and
get tested today i was tested last night
i'll get tested again today and tomorrow
and
and then go to the arena sunday and um
and we'll do the thing
the four-part documentary on uh inside
the nba you can see it on tnt
tonight is uh the role player that's uh
part two
what's the best item in your uh man cave
or your office there
um a picture of me and my dad is pretty
cool right there
all over your right shoulder yeah right
there
uh from back in 59 i believe
uh his last year with the braves uh that
was from like a father-son day
um what else we got here uh there's
georgia georgia jersey that says poppy
which is what my grandkids call me
um but there's a bunch of stuff in here
we call this we call this
the room because my dad sent me a
clipping one time
from the ajc that talked about our high
school baseball game
and he just and then he said here put
this in the room when it's built and so
you know he says that back in the in the
80s or the 70s and
so my wife and i said you know what
we're going to make the room so we just
got a bunch of stuff in here man
i have a very hard time throwing things
away
any sports emmys in there
uh there's one right there oh okay
probably people probably should have my
name on it
probably should have my name on it oh
without question without question have
you ever wanted and felt guilty that
i was out there in the audience and i
didn't win it
yeah i mean look i'm you're i'm going to
try to make a
try to answer this in a way that doesn't
sound like it's you know mamby pamby
bs um whenever my name is called on that
thing it's like
how did that happen because i always
look out there and i see
and you look at the list of guys and
every year it could go to anybody any of
those
you know five that are that are
nominated um
yeah but there's there's a special
bittersweet feeling when you leave the
stage and i
you and i lock eyes and but i always
wonder when i see you win
like how did i not win when we lock eyes
so
like how did that happen is what i say
well that's an upset for the ages how
did yes yeah but but i will say
i am pretty phony when it comes to
applauding
because i mean i'm used to being there
with bob costas
so when costas doesn't win i go i'm in
like this is mine
and yeah when he's not nominated
everybody feels like oh we're thrilled
not a chance
and then all of a sudden and the winner
is ernie
and then i'm like i got to be really
quick because i like you and i root for
you
but after a while i don't like you and i
don't root for you
so that's so kind of but you know what
what's funny
is when you just to the point we made
when
for so many years when bob was nominated
it was like okay good i'll
yeah i'll go but i'm just going to be
there to cheer for bob you know when
when his name is called
but those times when hold on
i'm nominated costas is not the guy
who's won 857 of these bad boys
we got a chance i don't know if i i ever
told you this story but there was one
year when costas wasn't nominated for
the
best studio host and i'm nominated along
with chris berman
and i'm not sure who else was nominated
but i'm at the table
they had tables back then and
i'm sitting there and chris berman is
talking to a couple of producers scott
ackerson
uh was one of our producers bob rauscher
was a producer
and he's telling them that yeah i gotta
thank i gotta thank tommy me yeah yeah
so he's going down the list of everybody
he's gonna thank
and then he looks at me and he goes good
luck well
i win the sports emmy ernie i come back
at the table
and it's as if i walked into a week
[Laughter]
i call my wife and i i s and she goes
you don't sound excited i go
oh hon it's bad i walked out of the
sports emmys
after that went down to clark's
and had a dr i brought the emmy and i
i sat at the bar with my emmy and i
just had i had a couple of beers because
i i couldn't just sit there by yourself
yes yes what a what an image
i know but i i felt bad that
like chris the reason why i won is
that chris opened the door for us to be
able to have fun on sportscenter
really chris is as influential as
anybody who's ever done this
but i felt bad i'm just there with that
sports emmy and he's right across the
table from me
and i felt terrible and i i just
remember going i'm going down the street
and uh just went to a bar and sat there
with miami
drank yeah my yeah
what a what a touching and disturbing
story
yes thank you that that is the title of
my documentary it's a four-part
documentary
touching and disturbing the dan patrick
story
play nice this weekend by the way okay
yeah of course yeah of course hey by the
way
chuckster will not be with us for
all-star coverage oh his daughter's
getting married
yeah how about riskiana do you think he
cries
do you think he cries oh no doubt i love
it oh
no he's crying right now i mean it's
it's not you know what
and i've been down that road and it's
fine did you cry
oh yeah yeah i did but you know what um
and see i'm i'm a sucker
you know the movie father of the bride
steve martin
because that that always tears me up and
so
i actually tried to circumvent me crying
too much at
maggie's wedding by watching the movie
like two nights before just trying to
get it out of my system
and all it did was exacerbate the
situation something i mean because i
mean you're sitting there
and you're about to do it you look in
your daughter's eyes and it's just like
oh my goodness
i gotta do it three times ernie but i
wasn't a mess though
oh it's dan it's the it's the
it's the greatest it you know there's
there's
this great part there's this horrible
part but
when they when they mesh together it
just makes for the most unforgettable
cool day you'll never forget it you got
to do it three times yeah i got three
daughters
yeah i've got uh i'll be doing this
again
yeah at some point too but uh but it was
you know
to do that and i was also my the best
man at my son eric's wedding
so i've had these wonderful incredible
moments
and and so if anybody ever has fun
saying oh
is anybody gonna cry you go ahead man if
if there's ever a reason to cry
it's it's moments like this i have
suggested to my daughters that all three
get married on the same day
cut cost and cut down on the tears
that would be uh that would be unique
you know what
i i think when i when when eric and
maggie both got married they got married
a month apart
in the same year um so that's why i'm
going to be working until i'm
93.
uh ernie great to talk to you and uh
happy to play a role
in some small part in the uh documentary
series uh oh i meant
i meant to say that too dan i'm sorry
because no they had so many
they talked to so many folks you
included and and the way our editors and
everybody
i mean they've done a spectacular job
and i don't know if you've watched the
whole thing or any of it at all
but the way they put put this thing
together and
with the comments of folks like you and
and wilbon and others
um and common and you name it uh
it's just they did a spectacular job and
it's it's not me just saying hey this is
great because
it's about our show but there are times
when you watch a show watch a
documentary
something like this and say man is that
well put together
uh it really is so thanks for thanks for
all your kind words about the show man
you would
you were awesome and if you win another
sports emmy because
of this documentary that i've been
praising
that doesn't seem right though um
if that happens i'm just i'm going down
to clarks
by yourself with your
emmy yeah yeah all right set me up sal
yeah have another round thank you ernie
have a great weekend that's ernesto
johnson jr the third tnt inside the nba
and uh part two of uh that four part
documentary tonight nine eastern it's
called the role player